well tonight it's Premier League match
between Manchester City and a snort has
been cancelled after players from the
London club came into contact with
someone who had covered 19 or abandons
us now an aura and who do they come into
contact whether and when more
importantly yeah they came into contact
with the owner of the Greek club
Olympiakos and the owner is a gentleman
called evangelist Mary nachus and as we
found out yesterday he has tested since
positive for the virus now the Premier
League say that this is a decision to
call off tonight's game is a
precautionary measure
but because after this match which took
place on the 27th of February a number
of Arsenal players and staff at the club
as well met mr. Mehra nachus it was
decided that following the government
guidelines which say that anyone who
comes into close contact with someone
who's tested positive needs to self
isolate for 14 days that they would have
to impose that on these players and
members of staff so the players
themselves are at home at the moment
until that period ends which will be
tomorrow so there is no man City Arsenal
game tonight we understand the players
will be back in training on Friday ahead
of their fixture against Bryson at the
weekend but this is the first top-flight
football match in the UK to be cooled
off as a result of coronavirus